[Music]
this morning on the dish chef
entrepreneur and cookbook author melba
wilson since opening in 2005 her
namesake harlem new york restaurant has
become a favorite stop for southern
classics for both locals and famous
names from around the world she's the
author of the cookbook melba's american
comfort and now for the first time she
will be opening up a second restaurant
location in new jersey i got a chance to
join her to see how she whips up her
magic
hi how are you doing harlem is a
community we all know each other chef
melville wilson knows her town there's a
lot of retail space so of course we want
to get them filled up her neighbors this
is one of my most dearest friends here
and her history here
so here we have frederick douglass the
monument the statue
the man it's why she chose this very
corner for her namesake i wanted this
corner because that block was one of the
most notorious drug blocks in harlem and
i wanted to show kids in my community i
don't want you to do that i want you to
come here you can get a job you had an
opportunity to make an honest living for
nearly 20 years she's devoted her whole
heart to melba's i'm born bred and
buttered right here in this community a
restaurant where new york city appetites
meet her south carolina roots crispy on
the outside
it gives us great pleasure here at
melba's
to capture this moment
and using food
as
a vehicle to bring people together she
does it with the foods we've all grown
familiar with there's her mac and cheese
oh
look at that you see that cheese string
that's what we're looking for
candied yams
collards and peas and rice you know
because i put hot sauce on everything
all of fusion ready to accept her
special homemade hot sauce
that's the way to eat that's the way to
eat it it's got to have a little taste
of something else on it right you got
some vinegar in there i like that
vinegar put some of this in here of
course that taste starts in the kitchen
where she showed me her special recipe
for a signature favorite southern fried
chicken and eggnog waffles like shaking
bait girl's shaking and baking it baby
come on in this small kitchen
you know i'm gonna leave the kitchen and
i'm gonna let you i'm gonna let you take
over every year they churn out more than
700 thousand orders and that's plenty
beautiful
it's the same waffle that i actually
beat bobby play with as in throw down
with bobby flay
happy juneteenth happy juneteenth yes
fitting that our dish is dedicated to
emancipation day freedom day
1865
abraham lincoln
we
finally have our freedom
and however as you stated it wasn't
recognized until last year
by president biden as a federal holiday
because to wilson every bite is steeped
in its culinary tradition collard greens
were extremely bitter
and it was the food that was considered
garbage food
and we had to take this food season it
up so that
we can go and and work back on the
plantations picking cotton et cetera
so it's interesting that it's now a
delicacy
um but as i like to call it comfort food
is food that not just comforts the soul
accomplish the spirit and the mind
wilson's career began on wall street at
an insurance adjustment agency but while
she earned a great living she didn't
even have a bank account i saved up
money under my mattress for years had
literally under your imaginary girl my
family's from the south okay
that's a habit that i inherited how much
had you saved up you don't want to know
tell me it was 312
dollars
she may be down home but she got her
training all over the map from the once
renowned windows on the world downtown
to a world famous eatery on 126th street
my aunt sylvia asked me to come and help
her up at sylvia's one day as in sylvia
woods the harlem queen of soul food
august will make 60 years at sylvia's
has been a staple visited by kings
queens
but most importantly loved by locals
yeah and she was a big inspiration to me
she passed away 10 years ago i see that
it still is very emotional for you yeah
yeah she gave me an opportunity and took
me from a cashier to back of the house
she just taught me so much about the
industry and wilson has helped to
oversee that industry in new york during
the pandemic as president of the nyc
hospitality alliance and the mayor's
covet 19 small business advisory council
it taught me the importance of being
able to sit down and converse
with one another
you know my grandmother always said to
me melby god gave you two ears so you
can listen twice as much as you speak
and it taught me the importance of what
my grandmother mia said listening
she runs her own mini empire with book
and tv deals all while managing through
the pandemic delays of her two new
eateries one in newark later this year
the other at one of her old childhood
haunts in central park the wollman rink
we only had one income coming in
we would go stand over the promenade
and we would watch people skate wow that
was our entertainment full circle moment
there will be a melbous
on the promenade
in the same spot that me and my family
used to stand and watch people skate
how about that
things are changing it allows her to
take in the sweetness life has to offer
even if it's simply in her favorite
dessert it is about the red velvet
you're tasting the hints
what is that taste
it's a little cocoa powder
chocolate yes oh my god
well i have to say
cheers cheers to juneteenth
yes
freedom girl finally
[Laughter]
we don't have any red velvet cake on the
table we got everything else oh look at
this
the fried chicken and eggnog waffles the
potato salad the collards the peas and
rice short ribs
and the mac and cheese with the string
unbelievable in her signature cocktail
it's got a little rum in it i don't even
know what the name is but it's good i
have no doubt and what is it
you know it's been a while since we had
a spread like this
and it's all vegan and diet approved yes
no calories whatsoever she's on fire
clearly it is on fire and she is such a
force
everyone in that neighborhood knows her
everyone in the industry across the city
knows melville wilson i can't wait to
see your place at woman rink